this current windsurfing record will no longer stop
and sometimes
here
they will wait three months
zacatecas
and
here
since this word is not enough
for romance
now let's
see
to jump pérez to
there
ah so
I say
yellow
what is the expression
and  kárbala is already in
addition to selling kaká
here it
will be worth jazztel
[Music]
here
ah
to use
the landslide
and you absolutely ga for each country you are
for space nothing
yes
to be
here
beristáin
each legs
for those
why
to be once
because I wanted  losing him
ah
suárez is not
how
yes
and sometimes he
has had
fax rules
to
[Applause]
[Music]
smart and that the proposals
know
yes
also
in the sector
call me
d
ramírez you are
you know
and further
on
but already
angels
h
yes yes
[Music]
watani
water
official watson
s sometimes
a
but yes
wow
and
something else
let's see
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
[Music]
other
m
and so improve
ah
later
camats
now
acc  edas
this faculty
but
and in the lower zone
ay
up to the palate
as long as this familiar person
ah
in the cda
james e
a
[Music]
ah
the tactic
for carlos close
to
official
ah
diego pons 6
ah why does he
add
serve he
is the most gentleman
cannes med
acz
ah
and
i
to mark al asad
ah
so
what are you going to do
if you want
in the canaries
yes
no
i
walls
yes
bach
no
the 3
so
they will stay
h
in the bank
it is not only
but we have
if I have
while
[Music]
here  no
I
just caressed
and down
thanks
i
ah
and
thanks
for being
break up of
course
and
the house
and media
la
from uruguay
gallas
marcial
ah
and
i
also sasha like
latakia
missing
bronze pages
here
i
ah
d
and now
how many things
la  bottle
says webcam
that is
here
the facility
etc whatever
the meeting [ __ ] gameplay as
[Music] you will
tie for another 3rd
but now you are going
for the meat to have
what
this race is for to disarm  r
altafaj
like this
here
if it is not going to
be attacked by
pac
craft
made
for this light blue
ah
good
bag you are meat
there are euros
the booths
ah
yes
way
we are not going to
believe who it is
ah
quesada
parker
not
the factor that fran is
h
that would happen
san sebastian